this a familiar ritual but these
unfamiliar times the queen's procession
to parliament paired back
in car not carriage and without her
consort
a single thrown now under the golden
canopy
the place her husband once sat now empty
my lord's pray was seated and the
chamber near mt2
tradition bent out of shape by this
pandemic
the government's first task to get us
back
to normal my government's priority
is to deliver a national recovery from
the pandemic
that makes the united kingdom stronger
healthier
and more prosperous than before and then
get on with delivering on its
pre-pandemic promises
to achieve this my government will level
up opportunities across all parts of the
united kingdom
the centerpiece of that new laws to
boost lifelong skills and training
and a new post-brexit state aid scheme
to help target
economic growth but not just the red
wall in this government
sites my government will strengthen the
economic ties across the union
investing in and improving national
infrastructure
it's the four nations of the uk too
commitments on transport networks
infrastructure and greenhouse gas
emissions
and in england changes to planning rules
to boost house building
but a warning too that current levels of
public spending won't go on forever
my government will ensure that the
public finances
are returned to a sustainable path once
the economic recovery
is secure an expensive pledge started
over two
proposals on social care reform will be
brought
forward over to the commons a chance for
mps to test the pm's plan
the labour leader doing his best today
we needed a queen speech that rose to
the scale of the moment
but instead this queen's speech merely
papers over the cracks
but days after thumping election wins
across the country
the prime minister unmoved but as he
looks forward
an acknowledgement he'll have to
confront the recent past as well
uh i i can certainly say that we will do
that within this
within the session it's essential uh
that we have
a full proper public inquiry into
into uh into the kobe pandemic and
uh i've been clear with the house uh
before
elected on a landslide boris johnson's
big plans for government were then
knocked sideways by the pandemic
but now he's dusted down that 2019
manifesto and the centerpiece remains
the same to level up the country but
there's controversy too
in this queen's speech there's unease
that plans to force voters to show
photo id for fears that it will
disempower
the already marginalized in our society
and what about plans to
to curb the power of judges to intervene
in political decisions it all looks a
bit like an already powerful prime
minister
further stacking the dice in his favor
fresh from election success and back to
pushing policy
the pm with wind in his sails but the
covert inquiry in a constitutional fight
with scotland
could still put paid to that beth rigby
sky news westminster